now of course we know you for lots of
things and two very iconic things one
Star Wars and another more recently Game
of Thrones as well we started Game of
Thrones first he had a very interesting
role in that didn't you now tell us a
little bit about what was like meeting
Melisandre well we we had to all night
shoots on the beach with the flaming
idols one of which actually caught a
light and burnt and that was there it
was it was very special but actually
very cold person
wonderful dawn I remember and and then I
very foolishly killed myself and I I
thought the the early way of getting rid
of the priestess was we would both drink
poison so I put the poison in anyway ah
we both drank the poison and I died and
she didn't and in between takes I said
to her I I'm not quite up to speed on
this why why don't you die and she said
I'm 400 years old
and I thought oh well fair enough you
know I thought that's a lesson learnt if
you're trying to poison somebody check
but at first that they're not 400 years
old
good advice that's very good advice yes
she's always like hey I think I guess
I've been like a supernatural Lady
Macbeth or some maybe think yeah yes I
do
I do actually do very nice eh she was
she was Dutch we had some ovett various
mutual dutch friends so that was nice
yeah we got on well
what was it like working with Harry's as
well and also with Stephen Delaney work
with don't you play stannis baratheon
yes yes I did
now I'd never work with Stephens Elaine
before I'm great admirer of his his
acting the funny thing was we like it
was it was day 1 of the second series
and we we drove out together at the
shoot and he said I'm Stephen and I said
I'm Oliver and I didn't recognize him
and it took me about we chatted away not
about films or theater at all about
various things and then after about half
an hour I suddenly thought you're Steven
salaita and I thought it's a bit it's a
bit late now to say oh I'd like your
work very much he's a very sort of
unassuming guy Steven yeah and you also
worked with liam Cunningham didn't you
who plays Dave Olson what's he like to
work with Liam Liam was also great and
we bonded actually over the RSC because
he did a play at the RSC for the Hubble
bed about shakespeare's daughter which
I'd seen and in which he really enjoyed
me and long conversations about that but
when were better on day one both he and
Steven said this could be the first day
of five years and I thought wow have you
signed on for five years what's that
going to be like I tell you one funny
thing about Meister kresson I was
originally going to have a beard and
then the makeup guy who funnily enough
Paul was the same makeup person who did
Star Wars my Star Wars and he said I
can't give you a beard because when the
blood all comes out of your nose it'll
stain the beards and we can't clean we
can clean a real beard but we can't
clean a false beard so he had to very
suddenly decide to give me side Wars
because he said the blood won't get on
the side boards
do you know very much about Game of
Thrones before you went into playing
maester Cressen no no I mean I'd heard
of it but I hadn't read the book so I
didn't didn't know anything about it and
I found it very doable to get up to
speed it's very complicated yeah have
you watched it still yes I bet I've been
watching it intermittently I think it's
great and it's really had an
extraordinary amount of success it's
interesting you can't predict how these
things will go and the fact that sort of
fantasy medieval can go all over the
world surely a remarkable I think yeah
kind of aspects of Shakespearean things
in there as well I think don't you yes
yeah yeah there is and of course the the
themes a bit like Star Wars are all kind
of epic legendary themes you know George
Lucas combed Greek legends to find out
your basic stories you know
you